hey what's up my name is samuel leeds i
am a property
investor literally oh my goodness i
started out with nothing i got my first
property age 17
and then i slowly built my portfolio
i've now been in the game for 12 years
i'm 30 years old
and on this video i'm going to be
answering your property investment
questions so
any questions you've got pop them below
in the comment box
and i'll do my best to answer honestly
openly i'll give you the good i'll give
you the bad i'll give you the ugly
for me property's been pretty good
certainly more good than bad and ugly
however i have seen warts and all you
know deals have gone wrong so
if i can help you open your eyes to help
you have success
but also avoid some of the problems a
lot of people go through i'll do my best
however
these q a sundays would be really really
sucky if you didn't actually ask me any
questions it would just be a blank video
so do me a favor drop a comment below
with your questions so if it's around
mortgages
tax hmos lease options rent to rents
speaking to people negotiations property
predictions
anything whack it below ask a question
and i'll help you as best i possibly can
also don't forget to subscribe turn the
notification bell
on and also hit the like button as well
to show your support
because i do a video every single day
you know i don't really
have to do this i do enjoy doing it and
the reason i enjoy it is because i enjoy
helping people seeing people succeed
so if you want to show your support back
hit like
subscribe let's see what we've got so
harry h says any advice
for aspiring developers
okay so a developer the difference
between a property
investor and a property developer an
investor is someone who will invest
their money in a property as an investor
a developer is someone who will actually
build a property or they'll buy a
property and they'll completely refurb
it
change its use maybe buy um
you know a pub and develop it into flats
so that's a developer
and then there's a property entrepreneur
and a property entrepreneur
is um is somebody who makes money in
property via things like
management and deal packaging so you can
make money in property
you can invest money in property or you
can grow
your wealth in property through
development so if you want to be a
a developer my advice for you would
probably be number one
if you're new to property i would
probably start with
small developments maybe even small very
small projects
like buying a small house and converting
it into two flats
where the level of risk is very very low
if you're going to start doing bigger
deals then i would suggest potentially
starting teaming up so maybe you bring
money to the table but team up with
somebody who's got more experience
and then that way you're going to be
able to learn from the project so it
really depends on your starting point
but i hope that helps
if it does hit the like button all right
next
dd and nn says hi samuel i'm 15.
15. crazy i met a guy today actually
he was um to be fair he was still young
he was 17. and
but he's 17 but he's actually got a
property business now he's working with
his sister and i was like cool man he's
a teenager doing well he said
i've been watching you for four years on
youtube i was like four years
you must have been like 13.
when you started watching me like of
young teenagers so hey respect buddy i
appreciate
i appreciate you um he said
is there a way i can surround myself
with people that know more about
property than me
also what should i do to start my
property portfolio
so i think yeah get surrounding yourself
for people that know more about property
news a really good thing
and how you're going to do that is by
you are going to put yourself
in the right room people are going to
say
in in years to come you got lucky people
say about me oh he got lucky i didn't
get lucky
i put myself in the right place at the
right time
and how did i do that i did that by
joining things like
bni i joined business networking
international when i was a teenager
this this business networking group
i was i was a kid i joined lots of
business networking
groups and property investment groups
started rubbing
shoulders because when you put yourself
in the right room
when you put yourself in those
environments you're out
you'll find yourself out of your comfort
zone but when you're out of your comfort
zone that's where you grow
so by the time i was 20 i was i was not
a normal 20 year old
i was a normal 16 year old but not a
normal 20 year old because of the four
years
where i continued to do that i hope that
helps keep going bro i hope to meet you
soon as well
glam glamazone does management company
for hmo find new tenants or just
looks after maintenance of the property
glam hmo management companies will do
whatever you
want them to do so they can find the
tenants
usually they'll charge a finder's fee
per tenant maybe half a month's rent or
a month's rent
somewhere in between um they can manage
the property
they can partially manage it they can
fully manage it you can give them um
authority to make decisions you can say
to them look if there's any maintenance
issues up to 500 pounds
just go ahead and do it don't even call
me
you know it just depends on the
management company and it depends on
what
what kind of level of management you
want and how hands-off you want to be
and they charge typically a hmm
management company will charge to manage
the property in full
somewhere between 10 and 15 is standard
um don't go for the cheapest
go for the best um yeah at the house
raz van gabriel i'm currently living in
manchester and i'm thinking about
renting a two bed flat in the city
center
and use it for dual intent i'll rent the
flat using a corporate agreement and
then i'll re let a room out to myself
while keeping the other room for my
corporate clients from airbnb and
booking.com
i have to pay rent anyways as i live
here for work so it might be less risky
starting out with this strategy based on
my calculations i'd only need 40
occupancy rate to break even
anything above that is profit do you
think this could possibly work
so do you have any advice for me or
anything that i should take into
consideration before moving forward
resume i think it's a great idea it just
works if you
it's like this is called house hacking
house hacking
is when you rent a property but then you
rent out the rooms or the room
in the property it's house hacking you
live rent free i think it's a fabulous
strategy and i look forward to hearing
how you get on with it and if anybody
else is watching this who's maybe young
and you want to move up with your
parents property or whatever i would
consider this as a strategy to
to to to look into the only thing you're
going to need is you're just gonna need
a landlord that gets it and is okay with
you doing it
um great okay um jay lewis says
just getting started tried to buy a
six-bed hmo i have enough money for the
deposit
um but the there's only one lender who
would lend me the money at a high
interest rate because i would be a
first-time landlord
have you heard of this before how can i
get started if i'm going to be penalized
for a first-time landlord okay jay lewis
yeah if you're going from
zero properties you're you're not a
landlord
and now you're wanting to buy a six bed
licensed hmo
a lot of lenders would consider you an
inexperienced landlord because you are
because you own no properties
and therefore they'd want to see six
months experience just owning a normal
buy to let property before they start
giving you money to buy you know the big
licensed six bed hmos i mean if it was a
four bed hmo you'd find it easier
so it doesn't surprise me that you're
you've only found one lender that would
do it
it depends on what they're charging you
if they're charging you five percent
i'd probably just pay the five percent
and then maybe
after a year or two when the when the
term ends refinance on a cheaper rate
if they're charging you 10 that's a
different story then maybe consider
either
finding a smaller property to start with
as your first investment
or bringing someone more experienced
onto the property
and and bringing down the rates so i
hope that helps
saves channel i have 400 000 pounds
best strategy for investing in property
please answer samuel
um it depends on what you want it
depends on what you want to achieve if
you've got 400 000 pounds
are you wanting to create cash flow are
you wanting to invest it and preserve it
so that it's just gonna slowly go up
over time
are you wanting both like are you
wanting to be hands
on or hands off it
really really depends if you've got 400
grand that's
that 400 grand you could do a pretty big
deal i mean
i've been doing deals with less than
that you probably you probably saw on
youtube
um a few months ago we put bought a
piece of land
in leeds for 210 grand
and then we're getting development
finance to build a big apartment block
five two bed apartments
the end value would be over a million
pounds you could do that kind of a deal
if you wanted to
or you could you could go and buy a
bunch of hmos
and get some cash flow no it just
depends
hey hit me up on instagram and i'm happy
to have a chat with you
okay last question bram glory says
i live in the netherlands and the house
prices have been rising for
years any advice how i could enter this
market well you could buy a house
and then you'd be in the market if
you've got money
it's pretty straightforward if you
haven't got money then you could maybe
consider buying a house on a lease
option agreement i've never done one in
the netherlands but i believe that it's
possible
well you could buy a house but agree to
pay for it
down the line and then in the meantime
you've got your foot in the door you get
it benefiting from
rent you're benefiting from capital
appreciation but you've paid
potentially a one pound option fee
because
lease option agreements sounds too good
to be true but when you
know how to do this type of thing just
opens your mind up so big
you know you guys want to learn about
lease option agreements for sure hey
if you've got questions for me comment
below smash the like button
subscribe and i look forward to
answering your questions next week
i also look forward to seeing you at one
of the live training programs
i'll leave a link in the description so
you can come and meet me live
at a free training program on the house
i want to meet you
i want to see you win get booked on and
i look forward to seeing you guys real
soon
you